thank you Mike Cody yeah hey I'm glad I
ran into you
what is that joke that you told recently
at the office everybody is just like
giggling about it all the time and I
haven't heard it yet oh gosh okay all
right it goes like this so there's this
woman good audience awesome
okay well this should go well so she
goes to her doctor and she she says to
her doctor kiss me I don't know if you
think the joke is over but it's not it's
actually just starting okay so I'm gonna
I'm just gonna speed it up so she says
to her doctor kiss me he says I can't it
would be unprofessional he says that
would be a professional she keeps asking
him
[Laughter]
finally at the end she says kiss me and
he says I shouldn't even be having sex
with you right now then what happens I
don't know then I guess she should
probably sued him for malpractice so you
know that wasn't that wasn't the punch
line you know that there's actually less
know this joke the joke was the punch
line was the only part that you didn't
laugh at you were doing weird character
the whole time so you weren't doing care
what character what character misses
you